so I'm making an effort and I've told
you that I'm making an effort because we
are in really pretty serious times to
contextualise Donald Trump's actions in
terms of why it matters and it's fun to
play clips of Trump saying silly things
or making a fool out of himself but
there has to be more there to really
make it worthwhile for us to use the
limited time that we have on the program
to talk about what Donald Trump said and
this is one of those times yesterday
Donald Trump gave a speech at the United
Nations and it was sort of a crossbreed
between an embarrassing campaign rally
speech and the rantings of a total
megalomaniac and I don't want to be
hyperbolic but this was truly one of the
most delusional and shameful public
speeches given by a president of the
United States certainly in the last
thirty years but probably longer and
most of the other contenders for the
most depraved and bizarre presidential
speeches would also be other speeches by
Donald Trump so at the United Nations
yesterday Donald Trump gave a speech
where he number one promoted a Trump
property located near the United Nations
bragged about the performance of the
stock market since he became president
of the United States bragged about the
unemployment rate within the United
States lied about the so called
unprecedented job creation rate that
he's presided over referred to North
Korean leader Kim jong-un as Rocket Man
once again
and lastly threatened to totally destroy
North Korea which would sort of be
threatening genocide now not only did
President Obama I think most of us
remember him Obama didn't make his first
UN speech about him he actually went out
of his way to say that his presence and
his speech were not about him sort of
the opposite of what Donald Trump did
President Obama actually saying during
his first speech to the United Nations
back in 2009 I have been in office for
just nine months though some days it
seems a lot longer I am well aware of
the expectations that accompany my
presidency around the world these
expectations are not about me rather
they are rooted I believe in a
discontent with a status quo that has
allowed us to be increasingly defined by
our different
and outpaced by our problems but they
are also rooted in hope the hope that
real change is possible and the hope
that America will be a leader in
bringing about such change really hard
to imagine reading that how Barack Obama
and Donald Trump are even the same
species never mind have gotten
themselves into similar positions of
power as presidents of the United States
a senior diplomat said to CNN who was in
the room at the time you could feel a
wind had gone into the room when he said
that people were taken aback here's
Donald Trump referring to North Korea's
Kim jong-un as Rocketman and threatening
to totally destroy the country of North
Korea a threat of genocide is what this
was the United States has great strength
and patience but if it is forced to
defend itself or its allies we will have
no choice but to totally destroy North
Korea Rocketman
is on a suicide mission for himself and
for his regime has anyone else noticed
that Donald Trump's face looks like he's
staring into the Sun all the time
even indoors that was maybe the most
disastrous moment right and Trump's
chief of staff John Kelly was caught on
camera
at a point during the speech face
palming and it was during that moment
even well it's hard to tell with Melania
but it seems that Melania even seems
concerned about what Trump is saying but
there is the new babysitter in chief the
chief of staff John Kelly who is visibly
shocked by what Donald Trump is saying
and there was a really funny debate
online about whether when John Kelly was
doing this it was about Donald Trump's
Rocketman comment or not maybe it was a
screenshot taken out of context maybe it
was earlier in the day before Trump's
speech has even started this is the best
a redditor actually zoomed in on a
picture of John Kelly's watch and
figured out that it was 10:20 a.m.
Eastern Time during the face palming and
Donald Trump's Rocketman comments were
made at 10:19 and 50 seconds a.m.
Eastern Time so this was the reaction to
Donald Trump's Rocketman
and threatening genocide to North Korea
that was the moment yeah I think the
diplomats were taken aback by this too
but just in a much different way yeah
and this had to have been a Stephen
Miller speech but you have to wonder if
even he would put rocket man on the
teleprompter I think Trump must have had
lipped that one listen I don't know
what's worse is it that someone wrote a
speech for Trump using the term rocket
man threatening genocide or that Trump
decided to ad-lib that all by himself
and then another really bizarre moment
from the speech was when Donald Trump
criticized socialism the entire room was
laughing at Trump Trump sort of looks
confused if you're watching you'll see
Trump looks confused you might even take
pity on him because he really looks like
the clueless kid that everybody's giving
a chance to speak at the microphone even
though he doesn't really deserve it it's
hard to believe this is even happening
the problem in Venezuela is not that
socialism has been poorly implemented
but that socialism has been faithfully
implemented uh-huh
very bizarre moment so why does this
matter right why does the United Nations
matter even if you don't like the UN
even if you feel that the UN is some
combination of outdated and impotent or
whatever the UN matters in the world of
international diplomacy showing up and
bragging about the stock market and your
real estate properties is a pathetic
embarrassment and this is a great
example of dunning-kruger I'll remind
you that the dunning-kruger effect of
this is this cognitive bias where
someone who has low ability suffers from
the perception that they really
understand things and their lack of
cognitive ability prevents them from
realizing that they don't understand
something and that applies to Trump's UN
speech how those who most need to see
this speech to realize how wrong
something is with Donald Trump they lack
the cognitive ability or intellectual
openness to actually see it for what it
is they see this speech and they say oh
it's Trump being Trump Donny boys
showing up and telling them how it is
not conforming to expectations of
oppressive political correctness or some
other inane drivel for all its
shortcomings though the UN has been an
effective arbiter of international
conflict the UN peacekeeping efforts
have been important there's been
successful war crimes prosecutions
including those of Charles Taylor and
slobodan milosevic there's been
significant famine relief spearheaded by
the UN environmental protection efforts
yeah there have been failures by the UN
sure Rondon genocide comes to mind
effectively stopping child sex abuse in
the Congo right with the oil for Iraqi
oil for food but the values of the UN
are values we should all share and the
mission should be supported and this is
making the u.s. a laughingstock right in
schrum point back to that idea that
we're funding 22 percent of the UN and
yet we're only one of nearly 200
countries there but I don't understand
if Trump realizes that having our allies
protected is in our own best interest
especially when he wants to beef up the
military for the exact same reason or
yeah it's it's amazing that he said well
we need a strong military because we
need to have this presence and our
allies and
shared community and whatever when it's
really just a crow Gnaeus hand out to
the military-industrial complex haven't
even gotten to talk about that hopefully
we will tomorrow and then at the same
time he has this totally opposite
perspective when it comes to groups like
the United Nations and the international
diplomacy community and the worst part
is forget about the normalizing of white
nationalism we've seen under Trump or
the xenophobia Donald Trump has
normalized being embarrassed by the
President of the United States
we no longer react to Trump doing
something embarrassing because we have
been normal we have adjusted to
constantly being embarrassed by Trump
can you imagine for a second being from
a different country right maybe one
where people are more accustomed to
following what happens at the UN you
turn on the TV you hear Trump bragging
about winning an election but losing the
popular vote you hear Trump referring to
the the genocide the total destruction
of North Korea very casually the world
sees us as a joke
Trump spills secret information from an
ally Israel to an adversary Russia in
the Oval Office our ally the UK is
victimized not by one but by two
different terrorist attacks after the
first one Trump goes on Twitter and
slams the Mayor of London after the
second one he goes on Twitter and
slammed Scotland Yard this is a joke I
do think that he keeps raising the bar
though and maybe that's why I'm not
completely desensitized to that so like
with that Rocketman comment I could see
him doing that on Twitter I just I can't
imagine the guy a president United
States speaking in front of the UN and
saying it and delivering that line there
yeah there's a total lack of context and
a total lack of just basic understanding
we're talking about a 71 year old man
here folks 71 year old man this is
embarrassing it's pathetic and it is a
danger that's why I'm talking about it
because it is bad for the national
security and world reputation of the
United States and the committed trumpets
are cheering it and they are going to be
cheering it all the way to you know
what's the equivalent laughing all the
way to the bank cheering it all the way
to the ballot box in 2020 and that's why
we need to be activating now for 2018
for the special elections in 20
and of course eventually for 2020 I'm on
Twitter at T Pakman send me your
thoughts the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership